[Musik]
man nehme reifen die wirklich greifen
viele ps unterm gesäß ein land in weiß
mit reichlich eis naja und dann braucht
man eigentlich nur noch das nötige
kleingeld und ein führerschein obwohl
geht vielleicht auch ohne da mögen
andere über klimawandel und co2 reden
hier oben in lappland da treten sie aufs
gas als gäbe es kein morgen
aber natürlich gibt es ein morgen da ist
schon wieder eins und es ist saukalt
minus 19 grad
kein wunder wir sind nur 50 kilometer
vom polarkreis entfernt und da haben sie
tatsächlich noch so was wie winter diese
bilder zeige ich hier eigentlich nur
weil sie viel schöner sind als diese
bilder denn so begann der morgen in
wirklichkeit mit einer verfolgungsfahrt
auf dem zugefrorenen see auf dem schon
um fünf uhr in der früh ein
erstaunlicher verkehr herrscht
schwerverkehr sogar hier drehen nämlich
die ungetüme von herrn sandström ihre
runden und fräsen das eis schön bröselig
gruselig jedes mal wenn er vorbei
brauchst dann kracht und knackt und
knarzt das raise beängstigend unter den
füßen
für unsere kunden reicht eine eisschicht
von 40 bis 50 cm schon aus aber für
unsere schweren maschinen brauchen wir
bis zu 60 naja 60 70 cm und im moment
haben wir 60 bis 65 cm
da stellen sich doch gleich zwei
wichtige fragen die erste können wir
dann vielleicht bald runter vom eis
bevor noch was passiert und die zweite
frage lautet was sind das eigentlich für
kunden die person strömen mit seiner
firma eis mekka bedient und da muss er
etwas ausholen denn sagt er die sache
begann in den 1970 er jahren
damals legten mein vater und sein kumpel
wie immer auf dem zugefrorenen see eine
landebahn für flugzeuge dafür
interessierten sich bald auch autor
ingenieure und die sollten dann gelänge
bahnen oder wollten kurven drin
und heute gibt es rund um das städtchen
arjeplog kaum ein gewässer auf dem nicht
zwischen januar und märz die
räumfahrzeuge irgendwelche bahnen ins
eis fräsen die einen zum auto testen und
die anderen zum eisigen spaß rasen
aber dazu später erst schauen wir uns
dieses arjeplog etwas genauer an
das ist nicht unbedingt ein städtchen in
dem die geschwindigkeit erfunden worden
wäre
im gegenteil das schnellste was es für
lange zeit hier gab waren diese
praktischen einkaufs schlitten
das ist die hauptgeschäftsstraße
downtown sozusagen
da gibt es eine bankfiliale ein
schuhgeschäft in dem man auch
staubsauger und küchenmixer kaufen kann
es gibt den unvermeidlichen lizensierten
schnapsladen johnnys angelparadies und
im supermarkt kostet das kilo
bauchfleisch knapp 60 kronen da kann man
nicht meckern
aber da schleicht sich da hinten doch
schon wieder so ein erlkönig heran so
ein prototyp der autoentwickler und
erinnert daran dass dieses 2000
einwohner städtchen im winter zur auto
hauptstadt europas wird da sieht man sie
plötzlich überall die testfahrer der
industrie auf dem eis und neben dem eis
jedenfalls in jeder garage und in jedem
schuppen und in jeder werkstatt sowieso
man hätte ja als laie nie gedacht dass
es an einem auto so viel zu testen gibt
und wenn man dann fragt bekommt man
keine antwort denn was hier vorgeht auf
den belastungs strecken und in den
kältekammern das ist strengstens geheim
keiner sagt was
und auch herr sandström und sein sohn
josef würden niemals irgendjemandem
erzählen was sie da heute in dem
elektromobil eigentlich testen
ich glaube es hat eher was mit der
heizung zu tun was er sonst drohen aber
so nicht bestätigen will
das hier ist nicht etwa der autofriedhof
von arjeplog sondern der schulhof von
schwedens erst im auto internat das
steht auch in arjeplog wo sonst
hier haben die klassenräume hebebühnen
und stadt biologie steht auspuff kunde
auf dem stundenplan
85 schüler aus ganz schweden machen dass
schrauber abitur auch frederik und max
beide 16
ich will entweder monteur werden oder
doch testfahrer
ich habe autos immer geliebt und wusste
aber nie so richtig was ich damit
anfangen sollte dann habe ich von dieser
schule gehört mit diesem video sucht die
lehranstalt neue technik talente
von der krise der automobilindustrie
haben sie hier scheinbar noch nichts
gehört
autos werden immer gebraucht sagen sie
also auch leute die autos bauen
reparieren oder eben testen immer wieder
dieses testen es nimmt kein ende
also entweder muss man ständig noch mal
was nach messen oder es macht allen so
einen heidenspaß dass sie gar nicht
damit aufhören können mit dem testen
nein da ist nichts mehr zu machen der
klapprige volvo ist final gegrätscht
vielleicht sollten wir ihn einfach hier
lassen und anzünden schlägt martin vor
[Musik]
aber da macht max schon den nächsten
oldtimer klar denn es ist samstag und
dem verbringen die auto schüler der
jahrgangsstufe 11 am liebsten draußen
auf dem see
[Musik]
doch zuvor ist ihr ganzes können gefragt
denn ihr fuhrpark ausreichenden
rostlauben muss irgendwie wieder in
schwung gebracht werden
[Musik]
mit viel kontakt spray und
überbrückungskabel können sie drei
zombie karren wieder etwas leben
einhauchen
zum glück schaut die einzige polizistin
von arjeplog in die andere richtung wenn
die rappelkiste unterwegs sind und zum
glück sagt frederik sind seine eltern
weit weg in göteborg
gut dass sie nicht alles mitbekommen was
wir hier so machen
es gibt da schon einiges was sie da
vielleicht ein wenig verunsichern könnte
das hier zum beispiel
[Musik]
holiday on ice in der version des arche
blogger auto internet
immer mit vollgas um die insel herum und
mal sehen wenn es diesmal zuerst aus der
bahn brezelt aha martin im mercedes ein
moment des innehaltens zur kritischen
selbstreflexion möchte man meinen aber
umwelt skrupel plagen hier die wenigsten
ich finde das ganze klima gejammer
ohnehin total übertrieben
schließlich stößt schweden gar nicht so
viel co2 aus und irgendwie muss man ja
auch mal cool sein und spaß haben dürfen
immer zu hause rum hocken geht ja auch
nicht
und während die kumpels unverdrossen am
wrack vorbei ziehen hat der bruchpilot
glück im unglück ein räumfahrzeug kommt
zur rettung
[Musik]
so sieht also ein gelungener
samstagnachmittag auf dem see in
lappland aus da wundert es keinen dass
die schweden mit diesem hobby nicht
lange allein blieben und ein findiger
franzose schon vor einigen jahren auf
die idee kam daraus ein geschäft zu
machen allerdings mit ganz anderen
fahrzeugen
[Musik]
das ist sein
stell dir eine seelandschaft vor mitten
im winterwald und darin fünf formel 1
strecken im maßstab eins zu eins sagt
der sprecher geheimnisvoll platz wo du
in den namhaftesten sportwagen der welt
über das eis driften kannst
so lockt eric gallardo seine kundschaft
aufs nordschwedische glatteis
als er 2006 damit anfing kamen gerade
mal acht im zweiten jahr 17 und in
dieser saison sind es über 500 kunden
die sich auf dem see austoben gallardo
war früher selbst testfahrer und dachte
irgendwann so was muss jedem spaß machen
besonders den franzosen aber circa 40
prozent kommen aus europa aus
deutschland der schweiz belgien spanien
und italien oder england und 30 prozent
kommen aus übersee amerikaner russen
chinesen obwohl die bleiben dieses jahr
weg auch heute sind deutsche da und
franzosen ein paar schweizer noch denen
er gallardo die spielregeln erklärt das
gelände sagt er gerade ist sechsmal so
groß wie monaco es stehen profis als
persönliche fahrlehrer bereit und die
autos sind speziell präpariert nebenan
stehen 30 flitzer bereit speziell
bereift mit spikes speziell verstärkt
gegen eis unfälle und ohne abs
damit sie beim bremsen auch schön
rutschen
[Musik]
ein renntag im ferrari kostet 5000 euro
wer es nicht ganz so dicke hat der kann
auch den subaru nehmen der kostet nur
3000 silverstone sepang und nürburgring
wer immer schon mal davon träumte in
einem 700 ps geschoss über eine formel 1
strecke zu heizen dem zeigen
rallyefahrer syrien und und seine
kollegen wie das geht ohne dass sich
einer dabei weh tut
eigentlich kann hier nämlich nichts
passieren und wenn er sich dann mit 200
sachen in die kurve legt dann gerät
sogar ein vollprofi wie sie ins
schwärmen
das höchste der gefühle ist in der kurve
zu bremsen sich zu drehen und
gegenzusteuern und dann wieder gas zu
geben und griff zu bekommen und hörst du
ihn gut
er ist ein tolles gefühl den ferrari zu
fahren aber fragt man sich ja in zeiten
der klimakrise gibt es nicht auch andere
arten für reiche männer und wenige
frauen adrenalin auszuschütten als diese
könnte man nicht vielleicht auch
federball spielen oder schlittenfahren
im wigwam am rande der rennpiste wo die
fahrer nach 30 minuten raserei ihren
blutdruck wieder sacken lassen sind zwar
bei manchen gewisse anzeichen einer ps
scham zu spüren aber doch eben nur ein
zeichen wir fahren den ganzen tag hier
aus spaß herum und für heizöl sprit
also das ist schon ein bisschen
egoistisch wenn man den zustand der
umwelt betrachtet aber ich meine der
fahren 14 millionen schmutzige diesel in
frankreich herum und wenn man das mal
gegen den ein ferrari auf rechnet dann
ist das gar nicht so schlimm
ich bin jetzt das dritte mal hier und
frage mich diesmal tatsächlich auf das
wirklich nachhaltig ist
ja ist es schon in gewisser weise
wenigstens beruhigt eric gallardo obwohl
auch er zugeben wird das eis fahren
nicht unbedingt als rettung für das
klima betrachtet werden kann
aber wir lassen nach jeder saison 3000
bäume pflanzen und jeder von denen
absorbiert in seinem leben 80 kilogramm
co2 und das sind zusammen 240 tonnen die
wir aus der luft holen und das sind
rechnet er vor immerhin 40 tonnen mehr
als sie raus pusten
aber schon ist die verschnaufpause
wieder vorbei und er tötet der lockruf
der eispiste und jetzt bloß nicht
trödeln
denn die wintertage in lappland sind
kurz und wer weiß wie lange das eis noch
hält
[Applaus]
[Musik]